good morning ladies and gentlemen
all right did we see your next witness
um
good morning your honor uh mr depp calls
kate moss to the stand all right
she will be appearing on your screen all
right ma'am can you hear me
yes can you count to five for me
one two three four five
thank you ma'am if you could raise your
right hand
do you swear for him to tell the truth
under penalty of law
i can't thank you
good morning miss moss or i should say
good afternoon your time your time
my name is ben chu from the firm of
brown rudnick would you please state
your full name for the record
kate smuss
miss moss where do you reside
london england
from where are you testifying today miss
moss
i'm gloucestershire england
miss moss do you know johnny depp
yes i do
how do you know mr depp
i had a relationship with him
uh did there come a time when you and mr
depp had a romantic relationship
yes
for how long miss moss were you and mr
depp a romantic couple
from 1993
to
1994 to 1998.
miss moss did there come a time when you
uh while you and mr depp were a couple
that the two of you took a vacation
together
to the golden eye resort in
jamaica yes
what if anything happened when you were
in jamaica with mr deb
i
um
we were leaving the room
and johnny left the room before i did
and there had been a rainstorm
and
as i left the room i slid down the
stairs
and i hurt my back
how did you and
please continue
and i screamed because i was in
because i didn't know what had happened
to me and i was in pain and um
he came
running back to help me
and carried me to my room and
got me medical attention
did mr depp push you in any way down the
stairs
none
during the course of your relationship
did he ever push you down any stairs
no he never pushed me kicked me
or
threw me down any stairs
miss moss have you ever before today
testified in any kind of court
proceeding
no i have never
why did you decide to testify today
objection your honor
all right let's be on the scope of what
we just talked about all right i'll
sustain the objection thank you miss
moth uh we have nothing further at this
time we greatly appreciate your taking
the time
to testify any cross-examination no your
honor all right you're free to go thank
you miss boss thank you very much